[Música]
alineada como un pentagrama de música la
viña más bella de las partituras de
lacote dog se ha dormido durante el
invierno de aquí algunos meses sus
deliciosas notas encantarán a los
conocedores Mientras tanto la primavera
se prepara cortando los sarmientos esas
ramas que estorban
esto ya no está bueno era del año pasado
Entonces lo quemamos después en
primavera los amarramos amarramos los
bastones así y tenemos ramas que crecen
y grapas habrá que tener un poco de
paciencia avanzando le sobra desde hace
un siglo en su familia se transmite este
viñedo cerca de boon un trabajo exigente
imposible ausentarse Incluso en invierno
el periodo de invierno es el período más
largo entonces Contamos con mucho más
tiempo para hacer las cosas y un periodo
que me gusta porque los paisajes son
lindos no se calienta trabajando y lo
que ocurre no es en la superficie es en
el interior Más bien a dos o tres metros
de profundidad porque el secreto de un
gran borgón se encuentra tal vez bajo
tierra en estas cavas donde el vino es
elaborado en tonel de Roble antes
simples recipientes los toneles hoy en
día son cuidadosamente seleccionados por
los viticultores que acuden a toneleros
reconocidos tales como Max y para
fabricar un túnel de calidad todo
empieza con una madera fuera de lo común
solo compramos Robles que tienen una
madurez de unos 150 años
necesitamos árboles con un diámetro
suficiente para poder producir maderas
de calidad que permitan obtener una
maduración del vino que lo conducirá al
apogeo si se puede decir así
un saber hacer secular y gestos sin
cambios transmitidos aquí desde hace
cuatro generaciones
alta costura moldeada con martillo
[Música]
El vestido aún está en un estado
descocido pero el tonel empieza a
volverse redondo luego hay que
calentarlo y mojarlo para volverlo
flexible y evitar los daños durante la
combadura
los comparamos con frecuencia al
principio de una embarcación madera
contra madera no hay pegante las juntas
con 100 perfectamente
puestas la una contra la otra con la
presión de los círculos que vemos lo
cual hará que sea hermético
una fabricación a la medida con roble
más o menos duro un calentamiento más o
menos fuerte
la intensidad tendrá una incidencia en
el color al interior del túnel
pero sobre todo en el vino colores
ajustados de vainilla cada
viticultor el túnel Es una herramienta
para la elaboración de los vinos para
estabilizar el color para muchas cosas
en el interés del vino pero el túnel no
debe ningún caso dominar el
luego hay que sellar el fondo con harina
y agua harina de trigo sarraceno desde
hace poco los clientes norteamericanos
ya no quieren gluten
[Música]
sirve para hacer la junta es una
impermeabilidad si no pones pasta hay
fugas
un centenar de piezas son producidas
aquí diariamente y probadas hasta dar
vértigo
últimos acabados el tonel es Pulido en
arcano tallado listo para ser enviado
el 80% de la producción se va al
extranjero tras pedido de viticultores
norteamericanos australianos o
neozelandeses
cerca de bongregor y patriar posee algo
que no se compra un don
este enólogo tiene como misión conducir
los vinos de esta casa por el camino de
la Excelencia
si se sienten estas notas melosas muy
ligeras notas oxidativas el vino llega
un poco al final de su recorrido Y
entonces hay que ponerlo en botella aquí
estamos aún con notas florales
relativamente frescas entonces aún se
puede continuar un poco la elaboración
aquí estamos en 16 meses finalmente con
una sola cepa podemos obtener miles de
lecturas diferentes y miles de matices
distintos
[Música]
el vino pasa entre 6 y 18 meses en tonel
antes de envejecer en botella a veces
mucho tiempo
de 1924 de la que podemos percibir el
color relativamente interesante aún no
muy madeizado y que es un vino
totalmente tomable e interesante para
degustar
es una joya porque cuenta es un poco más
que un vino es una historia un pedazo de
historia y siempre genera emoción de
gustar vinos de edad
en el corazón del Invierno bajo la viña
que se estremece las profundidades de la
code esconden secretos de cosecha
[Música]